what I want to do in this video is think
about how far can I see from the window
of a plane when a plane is at its
cruising altitude and just to give us
some numbers to work with let's just
assume that the cruising altitude that
we are working with the altitude of the
plane is 10 kilometers and the number
for the radius of the earth and so this
will be important for figuring out how
far I can see from the plane the Earth's
radius
let me just in a different color the
Earth's radius in green Earth's radius
in kilometers is 6,371 kilometers and
it's actually not constant throughout
the earth but we're going to assume that
for the sake of this problem that Earth
is a perfect sphere it actually is not 1
but we will assume that it's a perfect
sphere and it's radius is roughly 6,371
kilometers so given this information can
we figure out how far can we see on a
perfectly clear day from the window of a
plane cruising at an altitude of 10
kilometers and I encourage you to pause
this video and try to think about it on
your own
so I assume you've given a go at it so
let's draw earth let's draw earth and
this by no stretch of the imagination x'
will be a scale drawing either of earth
or of the plane flying above the surface
of Earth so let's say that this right
over here is Earth I would want to draw
it as a perfect sphere but I have not
but you understand my limitations now
let's see what we could do so the earth
the plane the plane is traveling at an
altitude of 10 kilometers so let's say
that this is the plane right over here
and this distance once again by no
stretch of the imagination drawn to
scale is 10 kilometers 10 kilometers and
then if we were to keep going down to
the center of the earth if we were to
keep going down to the center of the
earth that would be another 6,371
kilometers and when you think about how
far you could see your really your line
of
is really forming a tangent with some
point on the surface of the earth so
this is me and my plane and let's say
I'm looking at that direction how far
could I see well let's go I'm going to
be hitting I'm going to be hitting the
surface of the earth at some point and
I'm going to be hit I'm going to that
line-of-sight is essentially going to be
tangent to the surface so let me see if
I can draw it a little bit cleaner you
see if I so let's see it's gonna be
tangent to the surface so it's gonna
look something it's gonna look something
like that and so this is the furthest
point I could see the point at which my
line of sight is just handed to the
surface of the earth well how far is
that point of the surface going to be
from the centre of the earth well we're
assuming that earth is a perfect sphere
so that's also going to be 6,371
kilometers so that's also going to be
6,371 kilometers and the other thing we
know is that a tangent line is going to
be perpendicular to a radius so this
right over here is going to be a right
angle and all sorts of bells should be
ringing in your brain at this point
because we have just constructed a right
triangle and what we want to figure out
how far we can see well that's this
unknown side of this right triangle
decide that I have marked in X so we can
just use the Pythagorean theorem we know
that the square of this side so x
squared plus the square of this other
non hypotenuse side so 6,371 squared is
going to be equal to the square of the
hypotenuse so what is the length of the
hypotenuse well the hypotenuse is 6,371
kilometers Plus this extra 10 kilometers
of altitude Plus this extra 10
kilometers of altitude squared and so we
get x squared
I didn't wire with that in yellow but
anyway x squared plus 6,371 squared is
equal to what is this going to be this
is going to be this whole distance right
over here the whole distance is just
going to be 6,000 381 kilometers
and we're going to square that so x
squared we just subtract 6,371 squared
from both sides we get x squared is
equal to six thousand three hundred and
eighty-one squared minus six thousand
three hundred and seventy-one squared or
we could say that X is equal to the
square root of all of this business and
I could just copy and paste that so copy
and paste let's throw that right in
there
actually my radical is not big enough so
let me make my radical a little bit
bigger let me make my radical a little
bit bigger and then we can use a
calculator to actually compute this so
let me get my calculator out and this is
exciting because now we can finally know
on a perfectly clear day how far we can
see out of a plane so it's going to be
the square root of six thousand three
hundred and eighty one squared minus six
thousand three hundred and seventy one
squared which is going to be we deserve
a drumroll
it's going to be three hundred and
fifty-seven roughly three hundred and
fifty seven kilometers we round to the
nearest kilometer so X is approximately
equal to three hundred and fifty seven
kilometers in any direction so you can
see 357 kilometers in that direction you
can see 357 kilometers in that direction
so if you were looking at a map so if
you're looking at a map of say well
let's say you're looking at a map of the
US and your plane is flying across it
and this is kind of neat so let me let
me and once again this is by no means
drawn to scale but let's say that this
right over here is North America let's
see that's that Yucatan Peninsula
Louisiana our Lake Pontchartrain right
over there and then see that's Florida
and then that's the rest of North
America that's California just like that
it's Vancouver well I could keep going
Alaska and so on and so forth
so if you're flying in your plane your
plane is right here if we assume the
numbers we just assumed in any direction
you can see 357 kilometers so 357
kilometers would be
about that far so you could see you
could see that far in every direction so
it's kind of like seeing an entire state
are actually multiple states depending
what state you're thinking about of the
u.s. from your window if you could look
in every direction obviously if you're
only sitting on one side of the plane
you can't look out at one window but
maybe you could go switch to the other
side of the plane and see the other side
as well but you're actually seeing a a
substantive area when you look out of
the window from 10 kilometers which is
about which is roughly about 32,000 feet
in the air